Crawl back with you for Chapter 2. Every commercial and legal transaction carries a unique risk profile requiring highly targeted bond instruments.
The industry categorizes these into two primary divisions: fidelity bonds and surety bonds.
Fidelity bonds strictly guarantee the personal honesty of individuals, usually employees handling corporate funds like cashiers or collectors.
Do not confuse a traditional three-party fidelity bond with a two-party fidelity guarantee.
A true fidelity bond requires a prior conviction clause to be present before a claim responds.
These can be issued as individual bonds or as blanket types structured as name schedule or position schedule bonds.
All other obligations fall under the broader category of surety bonds, which are split into judicial and non-judicial lines.
Judicial bonds are required by courts during legal proceedings. In criminal matters, an accused individual posts a bail bond to secure temporary liberty.
In civil litigation, a replevin bond is posted to repossess personal property, while a supersedeas bond is mandatory in labor cases to stay the execution of a judgment pending an appeal.
If a minor is designated to receive insurance proceeds, a guardian's bond is legally required to protect those assets.
On the non-judicial side, you will most frequently handle contractor's bonds, which manage risk sequentially through every phase of a project life cycle.
The bidding phase: A bidder's bond ensures the participant has bona fide intentions.
If the winning contractor refuses to sign the contract, this bond answers for the cost to conduct a new bidding and covers the financial gap between the winning bid and the next lowest bidder.
The awarding phase: A performance bond, typically valued at 10% to 30% of the total contract price, guarantees completion according to specifications.
It covers the costs of delays and the financial premium of hiring a replacement contractor. Simultaneously, a down payment bond guarantees the exact liquidation of any advance payments given to the contractor.
The completion phase: Prior to final acceptance, a warranty or guarantee bond is deployed.
It allows the obligee to safely release retention money because it guarantees that the contractor must repair any hidden defects in materials or workmanship that appear within 1 year.
Understanding the product is only half the battle. Next, we must analyze the strict underwriting standards required to manage these exposures safely.